Hay que cantar Shulam Aleichem, Shulam Aleichem,
V'yahal b'deichem, V'yirichem matem l'adoshem,
Shulam Aleichem, V'yodat alayem, Ki mikav l'malayem izahem.
V'yoy yoy yoy voy a'hem, Ki viren los angeles,
V'yahem laishulem, Salen los angeles.
Por ejemplo, primero uno tenía que cumplir
comer un pescadito, y hay capítulo yiddish que hay que cantar.
Después hay que tener un caldito, cualquier cosa con pasta, con mandala, otro rezo.
Dos rezos.
Después que se toque carne, otro rezo.
Después que te dieron cimes, otro rezo.
¿Por qué hicieron todas esas cosas para Shabbat?
Primero, después de la comida hay que hacer un rezo.
Después de la comida, no hay que engañar al Dios.
Y en este rezo, hay dos palabras que son muy importantes.
Deyuhal tuve Shabbat, comí y estoy lleno.
Cuando tú haces el rezo y no estás lleno, tú estás engañando al Dios.
Una cosa más.
Que le sabe el mundo.
Aquí yo lo veo.
Cuando vienes en la noche, cuando comes el primer pescado,
que sepan adónde van mis palabras.
Tienen que cantar las miras.
Yo te voy a cantar las miras.
No tengo que ver el libro.
Meneyehu ve'simchu alayidim.
Yayim shabu shoyin yayim akhmudim.
Shoyim av ve'sayichu raf ayimum ayidim.
Kilayisishu kolberim viyahimdim.
Shemeyishu mayim eretz ve'yamim.
Koltsevum murayim givoyim ve'yiruhumim.
Panem ve'yudom vichayatz ve'yamim.
Kibiyohadoyim tzirelumim.
Yayim shevibel yayim shiglu v'soy.
Shurman ve'kadeshoyim ve'boyoyim ve'yasayshoyim.
Shabiskoyidish yayim kendoshoyim.
Kivoyishu v'seyl vikoymalakhtoyim.
Bemishvash shabos el yachlitzoch.
Kimkeru el afyukhuslayamtzoch.
Bemishmas kolchay viganaritzoch.
Echol ve'simchu kivukhoyruzoch.
Bemishnay lechem vikidishabu.
Beroyf matamem grikh naydibu.
Yishchil raftif amir samgimbu.
B'v'yasgoyel lecha oylem aba.
Que es, le oylem aba, sabote muy bien.
Por qué existe Shabbat?
Y por qué oylem aba?
Oylem aba es es, que una asa buena en este mundo, lleva todo para otro mundo.
Y, hoy, yo vive cincuenta años en Venezuela.
Hay veces que solo me canto el panguelito.
Imagínate cuando nosotros cinco hermanos, yo era el menor cantor con mis hermanos,
vinieron a las ventanas a oír como si cinco hermanos están cantando.
Eso se llama shmirz, bien esa noche.
Y en estos momentos, mi mamá era el más rico del mundo.
Se acordaba de su casa, de sus hermanos, de su esposo, de todo.
Las lágrimas corriendo de ella, como se acordaba comer.
Y cómo sobrevivían.
Y vino ese muchachito, primero Dios, no yo.
Primero Dios, no yo.
Yo soy nada, yo soy carne y sangre nada más.
Y Dios me ayudó en todos sentidos.
Yo quiero ustedes una cosa, que oyen bien.
El rey Salomón, dijo en su historia,
Que nadie no puede pensar que yo soy más vivo que otro, y que yo soy más fuerte que otro.
Eso no existe.
Cuando uno dice eso, no existe.
Cuando uno dice esas palabras, es egoísmo.
Uno es nadie.
Uno tiene saber en la vida.
Hay otras palabras que se usan en la sinagoga.
En la sinagoga.
¿Qué significa eso?
Cada uno en la vida hace errores.
No hay uno que hace errores.
Va a daba Moisés, Moisés daba, pero no hay escudo.
También hizo un error.
No hizo uno.
Moisés también hizo dos errores.
Primero.
Que pegó con un palo la piedra, pidió agua.
Y en ese tiempo, cuando uno creía todo en Dios,
Y cuando uno quiere una cosa, no quiere pegar una cosa.
No quiere que venga.
Y a Dios no dio acto.
Moisés Ardaina, se casó con una hija de una cura.
Dallá.
Hablaba todos de esa Torah.
Lo que no sabía, lo que no sabía, que voy a interrumpir.